i'm curious i mean season one of the
show was critically acclaimed it was
loved by viewers it got emmy attention
what's it like to not only make a great
show that you can be proud of stretch
yourself as an actor and an ep and then
hear that recognition and the reaction
from fans and critics and know that it's
actually being received the way that you
would hoped
there are no words for that i mean i
look i i took a risk with this so many
years ago i found the book i was coming
off a sitcom that everyone knew me from
and i thought okay
this is this is my new venture and i'm
either going to be accepted and i'm
going to like it or i'm going down with
the ship because this is going to be all
my fault um and i couldn't believe
how much people accepted it and loved it
i remember at the beginning i told my
team i'm like because i was so nervous i
was sick about this thing airing and i
said i don't want to read any reviews
let's just i did what we did and we're
proud let's move on and i remember i
woke up first thing in the morning and
my publicist texts me and she's like you
just this first one just came out i
think it was variety or hollywood
reporters you've got to read it i'm like
no no it was so lovely and all of a
sudden i i just started crying i was it
was like the first kind of door opening
to people accepting
this new show that i had really it was
my baby it's like someone saying they
like your baby i can imagine when you
have a baby you you'd like people to
like your baby
so
this was like all encompassing to my
life and to feel people love it and it
it to get the reviews were great and
then to get the nominations i i would
have never i would have bet millions
that was not going to happen and it's
funny because you have a successful
first season and it's great and everyone
loves it but then it's like oh god we
have to do it again for season two
so what were you most nervous about with
that because then you have pressure of
everybody being like okay wow me again
oh i was terrified it it definitely took
a lot of conversations for me to fully
get on board i was really nervous about
it because of that exact thing i'm like
guys we got away with it let's go
leave it
let's move on with our lives and let's
we're so proud and that's it and um i i
was terrified because i yeah you can't
it was good and we we did set the bar
really high
um but it's wild what we came back with
is bigger and better i feel like by
tenfold um the scope is huge you know
we've got great new characters i play
five cassies the mind palace is on a
whole nother level um i think we kind of
we swung really really hard this season
now that you've completed a second
season how much of a bigger and ongoing
plan is there for the show i mean do you
know
what a season three would be have you
had discussions about how long this show
could go are you thinking about any of
that no no
no
you know this was really supposed to be
one season
um and then we did this this awesome
second season but i
and i can assure you you are not the
first person to ask me this
um which it's very flattering that
people even think that there could be
talks of a third season
um
i want to see how it's received i want
to see after we premiere kind of how it
does and what people are saying
and um
yeah i need a little bit of a breather i
mean i did play five of myself and i
would like to not work with myself
anytime soon what was your reaction to
learning where things would be left at
the end of season two i'm guessing
you're a part of that conversation so
what did you think when you actually got
to read the script and see how it would
all play out and where it would all end
up
i loved the ending um you know the same
way we did with season one it could
literally be tied in a bow or it could
continue on um we did it in a way that
is really could go any which way you
wanted but i think it cleared up a lot
of story lines um it left other things a
little bit open
but a lot of the questions are answered
and i think for cassie
she's realizing that life that this life
that she's living is this is going to be
a um
it's not an easy thing sobriety and that
this is a lifelong struggle and it's
going to take her day by day you know we
start out with the season of her acting
like everything's great i'm just gonna
switch and my life is perfect and i'm
sober and i'm living in la and i got
everything going for me and you know we
find out very quickly that she doesn't
and this season of facing herself in the
mind palace and all these different
parts of herself that she hates so much
it's really about self accept acceptance
and self forgiveness um if there's not
anyone in the mind pals that she likes i
think that's what's really interesting
um it's actually just dawning on me in
this moment like they're all
parts of her she hates
and i feel like we talk about for
ourselves all the things that we hate
and we are so unkind to each other we
forget to tell ourselves the good things
and be nice to ourselves and you know
life in this world right now is is not
easy
and i think we all deserve a little bit
of um a break once in a while and
especially cassie what has it been like
to play these different versions and to
fine-tune each of them and make them all
different but all still pieces of the
same character it was bizarre um i'm a
very
as an actor i like to be in the moment i
am incredibly reactive um i would not
call myself a preparer
um i never know what i'm gonna do the
scenes are i like to be in the moment
and i like to react and i i i feel it as
i go and every take you will get
something different from me
shooting this way that the technicality
of it and having to work against
my mirror image and my doubles i we had
to throw that out the window i had to be
very exact in my movements in my words
um there was no i couldn't improvise
because i was working off a tape that
was locked if that makes sense so it
wasn't like the other me could work
against what i was playing with so i had
to be much more disciplined in the
things that i said my movements my eye
line um timing was oh my god if i missed
by a second it wasn't like anyone could
kind of work around that we had to start
all over it was a domino effect um i
learned that quickly i'd be like oh
so i really tried to not screw up the
timing because it was like oh my god
you're starting all over again um it was
it was wild we we actually had a lot of
conversations um with the team behind
orphan black they really helped us they
were a great
source because we used the same system
that they did so it was uh very
interesting and very unique and
different your sister is also in the
show and i love her character
what do you enjoy about having her in
the show was that character created for
her or did she just happen to
be the right person for that role
um first of all having my sister around
because she's my favorite person has
been a dream to be able to work with her
and in fact this season her character
went to iceland so we got to be in
iceland together so hello dream um
rewinding to season one no the character
was not written for her cecilia was the
part
and i we were casting
no one told me she was auditioning um i
we watched you know i was watching
dailies
sorry not dailies i was watching self
tapes every night and all the producers
were and i go to my cecilia file and i'm
watching everybody and brie pops up and
i was like
and i and i write the group i'm like my
sister auditioned and i go oh my god i'm
like okay i'm gonna take myself out of
this because i'm biased and i think
she's the most amazing thing ever so i
took my opinion out and i'm like this is
not a fair thing you guys decide and
this the studio approved her the network
loved her she got the job really totally
on her own and made it her own and i was
so
excited that we actually got to have a
little bit of a moment um on screen this
season because we didn't get to do that
last year cassie may be more aware of
her issues and the triggers for those
issues but those issues certainly aren't
resolved or gone but does it feel like
by the end of this season that cassie is
being more honest with herself and about
herself than she was before
yes i think she does make strides by the
end of this season i think that she
or she would have never gotten out of
that mind palace i i think she finally
except it was accepting accepting these
are parts of her personality and look we
all have that we have all parts of us
that we don't love but they come with us
they are part of our hearts and our
souls and we try and do better every day
and we all make mistakes every single
day and cassie was just putting on such
a show and i think it's her realizing
i'm not perfect
every day is a new day
um and asking for help and using the
people around her uh to help get her
through i know for instance for myself i
definitely have needed that this last
year i've i've asked for help and i've
been open to um you know to voicing that
and not being so you know they called me
the octopus last season because i had my
arms and everything and this season i
was there was so much going on in my
life and then so much going on in the
show i definitely asked for way more
help this time and it's amazing how many
people really do want to help you
especially when you're a person that
doesn't normally ask they're dove in and
i had such a great group around me
getting the things that i needed giving
me the time that i needed um so i'm just
glad that i spoke up but it is very hard
to do well thank you thank you for
making a great show this show is i i
love it you're great in it and i don't
know how you pull it off but thank you
thank you that's so nice thank you
thanks so much
you